so uh did you watch the Tyson Fury fight
I did I'm a I'm not a huge boxing fan
but I'm a fan of greatness and I like
combat sports and Jeff there we go
I I was lucky enough I actually watched
it with Sam and Sam is you know big
boxing fan and I think I know a lot of
Patriots fans would say the 28:3 is the
greatest comeback story in sports
I think Tyson Fury is the greatest
comeback so I explained the Tyson Fury
story so just so we can I'm gonna start
at the end okay
Tyson Fury knocked out Deontay Wilder in
the seventh round
Deontay Wilder is known as the baddest
man on the planet right never never been
defeated and he's he has a 96% knockout
rate right
42 fights 41 knockouts exactly only
person he hasn't knocked out was his
last ice in fury fight so Tyson Fury
started off he's this English boxer also
known as the gypsy king he was eight
weeks premature weighing in at one pound
right okay almost didn't make it just
from the beginning right one pound one
pound which is crazy because if you see
him now he's 69 1675 pounds yeah exactly
exactly that in that slim form which
we'll get into but his dad knew
greatness his dad was one of those
people that understood that this guy's
gonna be a champion and so we named him
Tyson after the great Mike Tyson
obviously years go by years go by he
starts training his dad was a boxer his
uncle's a boxers everyone in his family
his boxers and he gets to this point
where he's like the next contender
coming up he's 23 years old he gets
invited into wladimir klitschko his
actual fighting camp itself and kind of
going back to you guys's point last week
about hearing doubters everyone always
told Tyson Fury you're gonna go to this
camp but wladimir klitschko is the King
right even you're there he's gonna
batter you as a sparring partner and so
he was training with me is like this
guy's not that great I'm gonna get into
his head these guys they weren't even
boxing against each other this time not
opponents so during the training camp
itself they go into the sauna okay have
you heard this honest or not sorry the
story now yeah I'm excited this is maybe
my favorite story in sports so everyone
knows and everyone tell us ice in fury
when we Klitschko is not just the King
of the Ring
why don't we Klitschko is the king of
the sauna okay look everyone here Henry
the photo what wladimir klitschko looks
like this time he's a monster yeah he's
enormous
he's a Russian monster he's a Russian
monster Ukrainian Russian monster so
this guy's huge so they go into an Tyson
Fury's everyone's telling him you got to
get out of this on as fast no one who
can last as long as them and he says I'm
not even fighting this guy I'm gonna get
into his head I want to beat him now
because I know I'm gonna be champion
later and people say I can't do
something I'm gonna do it okay
so they get in there it's hot it's
really warming up five minutes go by ten
minutes go by there's about a dozen
people in there
people are dropping on right someone's
leaving another person's leaving about
20 minutes come in and it's only Tyson
Fury in line with Coach go left
so Vladimir Klitschko you know he stands
up Tyson fair he's like thank goodness
he's about to pass out why don't we
Klitschko turns up the heat
yeah so Tyson curry says I can't let
this guy get in my head everyone thinks
I can't beat him I'm gonna get up - he
gets up you know what he does turns it
up grabs the newspaper lady grabs the
newspaper write another 25 minutes go by
then legitimately as hot as the sauna
can go and Klitschko finally leaves
Tyson Perry win seems like I can't just
leave right now he'll know about I was
just trying to beat him wait a little
bit longer basically passes out years go
by three four years go by Tyson Fury's
the number one contender Chris cares a
champion which goes the champion he
hasn't lost in something like 11 years
11 years hasn't lost right everyone's
like Tyson Fury you cannot beat
Klitschko Tyson Fury goes you know what
I know all of you think I can't do this
I'm gonna do it on his home court I
don't come to the UK I don't want to
fight you at Wembley I want to fight you
in like Eastern Europe so they fight in
Germany and then so in the pre-fight
they do a face to face similar to how we
are now Tyson Fury brings up this honor
issue
Klitschko everyone look at the clip is
so like pretend like it didn't happen
like he couldn't remember it and Tyson
Fury says after the fight he knew that's
when he beat him and he goes in and he
batters
right he batters Klitschko wins right
becomes the lineal champion 3 3 class
champion whichever by the way I love
this lineal champion the lineal champion
for those who don't follow boxing is
just you're you beat the man who beat
the man who beat the man who beat the
man all the way back in time to the
first man exact and so you have taken
the champion you took the champion
yes and nobody's taking you out yet Neil
champion he's the lineal champ so this
is 2015 so the thing was is that after
this fight Tyson Fury didn't go on and
actually fight Klitschko again right he
balloons up to 400 pounds he's at the
mountaintop he's like is this it is this
it and he's hurting from everyone he
couldn't do it again he can't do it
again
it is finally somewhat getting to him he
becomes addicted to drugs he gets
addicted to booze he's 400 pounds and
everyone says I knew it I knew Tyson
Fury was a bum right right and so
finally something in his mind clicks
2017 this video comes out him jogging
his face is monstrous size of a bass it
looks like someone who ate Tyson Fury
exactly and he there's this video
everyone's gotta see it and he said he
says it's like Deontay Wilder I'm coming
for you and everyone says he's never
talked about he's failed so many times
he'll never come back
yeah and little obviously he fights some
he comes back he drops a hundred and
fifty pounds it was a draw the first
fight time comes back they're like you
know what Tyson Fury is he's not coming
back it's gonna be the WWE thing he got
his payday he's gonna go drink again
comes back obviously this past Saturday
knocks out actually knocks out the
nachus knockout artist a hundred percent
no one thought he could do it right and
so I just thought it was this really
interesting story for a lot of the
points that even we were talking about
last week or you guys were talking about
last week when it came down to people
saying no right people not wanting to
see success happen everyone wants to see
you blues and he took that as energy
came back like four separate times right
from the brink like four separate times
and made it happen I just thought it was
just I can tell you're kind of like me
in that maybe the thing I respect most
is someone's mentality yes their mental
toughness and and I don't I don't even
think I'm particularly great at this but
it's something that I've decided is sort
of the number one most important asset
is how how is your mindset 104,000
mindset where things are good are you
grateful or you're appreciative are you
a giver to others yeah how is your
mindset when things are bad yes are you
resilient do you do you turn the
disadvantages into advantages and
mindset is
number one that's why you love fury yes
doesn't matter that he knocked out my it
matters how his mind worked he was at a
point where most people break Angela
Duckworth would call it grit right what
this guy has right like when I read that
book all I could think about was Tyson
Fury yeah but it all comes down to
mindset all the great leaders have it
Admiral William McRaven is another great
example obviously one of the greatest
Admirals and Navy SEALs history on
special ops history same thing he's a
great leader because of how his mindset
is right this is why sports is greats
the metaphor it's the grand metaphor for
life
uh-huh who cares about these guys
punching each other in the head or
throwing a ball in a hoop but it is the
great many real post a bunch of the
things that we talked about I want
everyone to go to the hustle and my
first million everyone on Twitter and I
want you to all look at these links and
be inspired yes love it
it was a great fight it was very dirty
and he gave us a nice little ballot and
Oh Mike he sings a song when he lands
which is hilarious and part of like his
marketability is that he's just like
crazy character he was dancing before
the fight yeah well there was stress you
can he was literally dancing by the way
super lame excuse by Deontay Wilder that
his costume was too heavy and that's why
he lost no you lost ghosts I got very
punch in the head yeah
[Music]